He estado siguiendo los pasos de mi madre
desde antes de nacer
y no he descubierto cómo detenerlos.
Y a medida que envejezco, se vuelve más difícil.
No, en serio, cada vez es más difícil.
(Risas)
Mi madre me enseñó muchas cosas
sobre todo, que el amor manda sobre todo.
Ella me enseñó ese amor
es una acción,
no es un sentimiento
El amor es una forma de ser, es una forma de hacer,
es una forma de escuchar y es una forma de ver.
DW: Y también, sobre la idea del amor,
los fotógrafos,
buscan amor cuando hacen fotografías.
Miran y miran y encuentran el amor.
Criado en el norte de Filadelfia,
Estaba rodeado de personas de mi familia y amigos
quienes hicieron ls fotografías
y usaron la cámara familiar como forma de contar una historia sobre la vida,
sobre la vida de alegría,
sobre lo que significaba convertirse en una familia en el norte de Filadelfia.
Así que pasé la mayor parte de mi vida buscando imágenes
que reflejan ideas sobre el amor negro, la alegría negra
y sobre la vida familiar.
Es importante pensar en la acción del amor por encima de las reglas como un verbo.
HWT: A veces me pregunto si el amor de mirar es genético,
porque, como a mi madre,
me encantan las fotografías desde antes incluso de recordar.
A veces pienso que, después de mi madre y su madre,
la fotografía y las fotografías fueron mi primer amor.
Sin ofender a mi padre,
pero eso es lo que se obtiene de llamarme "jamón"
donde quiera que vayas.
Recuerdo que cada vez que iba a la casa de mi abuela,
ella escondeía todos los álbumes de fotos
porque tenía miedo de que preguntara,
"¿Quién es ese en esa foto?"
y "¿Quiénes son para ti y quiénes son para mí?
y ¿qué edad tenías cuando se tomó esa foto?
¿Qué edad tenía yo cuando se tomó esa foto?
¿Y por qué eran en blanco y negro?
¿Era el mundo en blanco y negro antes de que yo naciera?
DW: Es interesante,
al pensar en el mundo en blanco y negro.
Crecí en un salón de belleza en el norte de Filadelfia,
el salón de belleza de mi madre, mirando "Ebony Magazine"
viendo fotos que contaban historias que a menudo no aparecían en las noticias,
pero en el álbum familiar
Quería que el álbum familiar fuera enérgico para mí,
una forma de contar historias,
y un día me encontré con un libro en la Biblioteca Pública de Filadelfia
llamado "The Sweet Flypaper of Life" de Roy DeCarava y Langston Hughes.
Creo que amis 7 años lo que me atrajo fue
el título, el papel matamoscas y lo dulce,
pero a los siete años,
miraba las bellas imágenes que hizo Roy DeCarava
y luego busqué la forma de contar una historia sobre la vida.
Y buscarme es el acto que básicamente cambió mi vida.
HWT: Mi amigo Chris Johnson me dijo que cada fotógrafo,
cada artista, esencialmente trata de responder una pregunta,
y creo que tu pregunta podría haber sido,
"¿Por qué el resto del mundo no ve lo hermosos que somos,
y ¿qué puedo hacer para ayudarlos a ver a nuestra comunidad como yo?"
DW: Cuando estudiaba en la escuela de arte,
probable sea cierto,
tuve un profesor que me dijo que ocupaba el espacio de un buen hombre
Trató de reprimir mi sueño de convertirse en fotógrafa.
Intentó avergonzarme en una clase llena de fotógrafos varones.
Me dijo que estaba fuera de lugar y fuera de orden como mujer,
y él continuó diciendo que todo lo que podía y debería hacer
es tener un bebé y dejar a un buen hombre su asiento en esa clase.
Me sorprendió el silencio en esa experiencia.
Pero tenía mi cámara, y estaba decidido a demostrarle
que era digna de un asiento en esa clase.
Pero en retrospectiva, me pregunté: "¿Por qué tengo que demostrarlo?"
Tenía mi cámara, y sabía que debía probarme a mí mismo
que marcaría una diferencia en la fotografía.
Me encanta la fotografía, y nadie me impediría hacer fotos.
HWT: Entonces fue cuando llegué yo.
DW: Sí, ese año me gradué y me quedé embarazada.
Sí, él tenía razón.
Y te tuve a ti,
y me quité ese lenguaje sexista que él usó en mi contra
y recogí mi cámara e hice fotografías diariamente,
e hice fotos de mi barriga embarazada
mientras me preparaba para la escuela de postgrado.
Pero también pensé que faltaban fotógrafos negros
en los libros de historia de la fotografía,
y estaba buscando formas de contar una historia.
Y encontré el libro de Gordon Parks "Una elección de armas"
que era su autobiografía.
Empecé a fotografiar y hacer imágenes,
y escondí esa hoja de contacto que hice de mi vientre embarazado,
y luego me inspiraste a crear una nueva pieza,
una pieza que decía: "Una mujer tomando el lugar de un hombre bueno"
"Tomaste el espacio de un buen hombre"
y luego usé ese lenguaje y lo invertí y dije:
"Hice un espacio para un buen hombre, tú".
(Aplausos)
HWT: Gracias, ma.
Igual que la madre, el hijo.
Crecí en una casa llena de fotografías.
Estaban en todas partes, y mi madre convertía la cocina en un cuarto oscuro.
Y no solo había fotos que ella tomaba
y fotos de miembros de la familia.
Había fotos en la pared de y por personas que no conocíamos,
hombres y mujeres que no conocíamos.
Gracias, ma.
(Risa)
Tengo mi propio tiempo.
¿Vieron como me empujaba?
(Risas)
Cuerdas de marionetas.
Crecí en una casa llena de fotografías.
(Aplausos)
Pero no eran solo imágenes de hombres y mujeres que conocía,
sino con fotos de personas que no conocía,
y era bastante obvio que por lo que aprendí en la escuela,
el resto del mundo tampoco los conocía.
Y me llevó mucho tiempo descubrir qué estaba tramando,
pero después de un tiempo, lo descubrí.
Cuando tenía nueve años, ella publicó este libro,
"Black Photographers, 1840-1940: Una bio-bibliografía".
Y me asombra ver que
en 1840 los afroamericanos hacían fotografías.
¿Qué supone pensar en ello
en una época que sucedió dos o tres décadas antes del final de la esclavitud,
cuando estas personas estaban aprendiendo a leer,
tenían que aprender matemáticas,
tenían que estar a la vanguardia de la ciencia y la tecnología,
hacer matemáticas, física y química solo para hacer una sola fotografía?
¿Y qué los impulsó a hacer eso sino al amor?
Ese libro la llevó a su siguiente libro, "Black Photographers, 1940-1988".
y ese libro llevó a otro libro, y otro libro, y otro libro,
y otro libro, y otro libro,
y otro libro, y otro libro, y otro libro, y otro libro,
y otro libro, y otro libro, y otro.
(Aplausos)
Y a lo largo de mi vida,
ella ha editado y publicado docenas de libros
y comisariado numerosas exposiciones en todos los continentes,
no todo sobre fotógrafos negros, sino todo inspirado en la curiosidad
de una niña negra del norte de Filadelfia.
DW: Lo que encontré es que los fotógrafos negros tenían historias que contar,
y necesitábamos escuchar.
Y luego encontré y descubrí
fotógrafos negros como Augustus Washington,
quien hizo estos hermosos daguerrotipos
de la familia McGill a principios de los años 1840 y 50.
Las historias de fotógrafos negros tendían a ser diferentes,
y tenían una narrativa diferente sobre la vida negra durante la esclavitud,
pero también trataban de la vida familiar,
la belleza y contar historias en la comunidad.
No sabía cómo vincular las historias,
pero sabían que los maestros debían saber esta historia.
HWT: Creo que fui el primer estudiante de mi madre.
Involuntariamente e involuntariamente, cuerdas de marionetas.
Decidí tomar una cámara,
y pensé que debería hacer mis propias fotos
sobre el entonces y ahora y el ahora y el entonces.
Pensé en cómo podría usar la fotografía
para hablar sobre lo que sucede fuera del marco de la cámara
puede afectar lo que vemos dentro.
La verdad siempre está en manos del real creador de imágenes
y depende de nosotros considerar realmente lo que se recorta.
Pensé que podría usar su investigación como un punto de partida
de las cosas que veía en la sociedad
y quería pensar cómo usar imágenes históricas
para hablar sobre el pasado presente
y pensar cómo hablar
sobre la perenne lucha por los derechos humanos y la igualdad de derechos
a través de mi apropiación de fotografías
en forma de escultura, video,
instalación y pinturas.
A pesar de todo, una pieza me ha afectado sobremanera y
continúa inspirándome.
Se basa en esta fotografía de Ernest Withers,
que tomó esta foto en 1968
en la Marcha de Trabajadores de Saneamiento de Memphis
de hombres y mujeres de pie colectivamente para afirmar su humanidad.
Tenían carteles que decían "soy un hombre"
y encontré eso asombroso, porque la frase con la que crecí
no era "Yo soy un hombre", era "Yo soy el hombre" y
me sorprendió cómo pasó de esa afirmación colectiva durante la segregación
a esta afirmación aparentemente egoísta tras la integración.
Y quería reflexionar sobre eso,
y decidí volver a mezclar ese texto de tantas maneras como posibles,
y me gusta pensar en la línea superior como una línea de tiempo
de la historia estadounidense, y la última línea como un poema,
y dice,
"Yo soy el hombre. Quién es el hombre. Tú el hombre. Qué hombre.
Yo soy hombre. Yo soy muchos. Yo soy, soy yo
Yo soy, yo soy. Soy un hombre.
DW: Guau, tan fascinante.
(Aplausos)
Pero lo que aprendemos de esta experiencia
es la dos palabras más poderosas en el idioma inglés es "Yo soy".
Y cada uno tenemos la capacidad de amar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)